amaran
俺の名前は斎藤一
政界でも十数の盗み人だ
俺の特技はあるロックまあ簡単に言えばスマホのパスワード会社
今日のターゲットはこの参入
鉄円盤
吉光虫めがねっ
ミッションは簡単こいつら3人の誰でもいいから一人のパスワードを突破種
それだけが俺に与えられた使命狙えばいいましたね
最初のターゲットは
勾配なね早期とやめておこう
こいつは鋭いにバッチの馬鹿にしようかっ
いきありません a
[音楽]
な方法で得られる
グンゼ人名集だ言って
でございません
[音楽]
can use カードローンええええええ
よしなんとかスマホをゲットできたさあいつらはユーチューバー
そして頭が悪い適当に000でどうだ
違うだぞ
11一度だ
1234違う
そうだあいつの本名は親へず哲也会津の方明王や
いっっ
違うぞ
となるとサイプターゲットが大好きな下ネタどうだ
[音楽]
me
ん
dj ん
ということであった
裏地を1点多いん
[音楽]
ん
以下にばれずにスマホをターゲットに返すかも回答のポイント
そうこのように静かに忍び寄り
こっそりと置いておく
カメラを踏んづけてしまった失態
ええええええ
[音楽]
ん
小ネタて調べる
いい
あっていた
[音楽]
++あ探すがと思いますとはー
meja
me
んわ
うーん
me
voodoo
すそれでは今日も人生
[音楽]
マニュアルのない
これ
[音楽]
ガー ana
ああそういうことか
何をしてると思ったーーこれが最後のチャンスなんだ
これで解ければあるのかっていうね
死滅
動けたそんな愛のことはないだろう
はぁ
んだったそいつたんどるよ
1月中のながら
[音楽]
まさかな
17て言っとる ana
[音楽]
ななんだっ
もし蜜
ルイージ見習って
トシミカ
[音楽]
都墨田の貴様
授業
ねぇ
me
うううう
あっはぁ
さあなんて簡単なんだ
ちょっとベルトですアルファお前がそう
んないからとしみだよ
キサナれな空と着るか違うと思うけど
93年の2月中4日生まれ
違うんそうならない
アッサーの1つはアジアレベルが違うとり台
どこだったキャ iq
どこへだけ人新倉じゃないと思う
111か1ないな
全部同じじゃないのがアゲートに
ポッポパックスポット